today we are going to discuss about
mutability data analysis and then get a
hands-on practice on t bioinfo server
for the same
so what is mutability mutability in
simple terms describes the observed rate
of a given position to change or mutate
the mutability module generates a table
in which each genomic position or a
nucleotide is assigned with the most
probable nucleotide variant
the variant is assigned based on the
maximum of the low thresholds of
confidence intervals
transformed to quasi-normal distribution
for each alternative in the given
position
so in the omics logic learn lesson on
mutability we discussed about mutation s
ps and mutability
now let's learn how we can use this
information to analyze ngs data from
different sources locations and ears to
derive by logical meaning regarding the
data
in the next steps we are going to learn
how we can perform mutability data
analysis on ncs data using tbioinfo
server
we will also go through the complete
pipeline for mutability analysis
and explain it stepwise eventually you
will learn about the interpretation of
the results as well
to build a mutability pipeline choose
mutation variant analysis pipeline under
the genomics section on the t bioinfo
server
now let's set the parameters
for type of reference genome it should
be our genome gtf since here we are not
using a model organism we need to
provide reference genome for desired
organism
that is plasmodium falciparum in our
example
the format of ngs data needs to be fastq
then we need to choose single or pair
end reads here we are going to choose
pair end since in this example we have
paired entry data
to upload the ngs data
the input data can be uploaded by using
multiple options files can be uploaded
as ftp or svl links they could also be
uploaded as ncbi run table
or as dot txt files containing svl or
ftp links for all the samples
next we need to upload the reference
genome of selected organism here we are
using plasmodium falciparum click on add
more option to create get link option
subsequently paste links for faster
files of reference genome and gtf or gff
file for reference to norm
next choose the groups drag the samples
into respective groups
here we are considering 2009 samples as
control groups and 2015 samples as
treatment groups
now let's start to build the pipeline
to begin with click on the start button
you will get a pop-up click on ok to
start the pipeline
to align the raw sequence reads of ngs
data here we are using the boutique
algorithm
by clicking on the bounty option you
will get a pop-up and click on save to
proceed further
next we need to perform per nuclear
mutation analysis
pernucle is an algorithm that calculates
the per position coverage of the
reference genome by all variants
the output of this module is a table
with all the positions of the genome and
the calculated coverages of each
position by each variant
next we need to perform
bionom
95 mutation called bionom 95 is a module
that performs calculation of the 95
percent confidence interval for
frequency of every variant at the genome
position based on wilkes theorem for
binomial distribution
to learn more about this module you can
refer to the learn lesson on genomics on
omics logic learn portal
next we need to perform mutability
the mutability module generates a table
in which each genomic position on
nucleotide is assigned to the most
probable nucleotide variant the variant
is assigned based on the maximum of the
low thresholds of confidence intervals
for each alternative in the given
position
the last step is to end the pipeline and
give it a name
this pipeline can take more than 72
hours to complete or more than that
depending on the number of samples
uploaded please keep patience when
looking at the results
okay so now we have our results
in the mutability table
each genomic position or nucleotide is
assigned to the most probable nucleotide
variant
and the variant is assigned based on the
maximum low thresholds of confidence
intervals
usually this table is very large
sometimes difficult to handle on the pc
systems
in order to understand and visualize
whether the mutation or mutation
frequency information can help us
distinguish various classes of the
samples in our data
we can use mason idea to understand and
visualize the patterns within our data
based on new features or principal
components
since the mutability output files are
usually very large to handle especially
if you have large number of samples that
would be more than 20 samples let's say
so it's better to not download the
complete file instead we can use the svl
link of the file
to do so first we need to go to the
download outputs of the mutability
pipeline next click on download job
temporary files
subsequently need to click on svls where
you will get
heterozygosity transform folder
in this folder you will get all
files.svl
open this file in dot txt format
and copy the full link of the file named
as heterozygosity
log
transform.txt now to run pca go to the t
bioinfo server
click on the unsupervised analysis
module under the data mining section
although there are number of options
available to upload file on the server
since mutability output files are
usually very large to handle specially
if you have large number of samples it's
better to use the svl link of the file
paste the link of the file in the blank
box
and run pca
to run pca click on the start button
and now click on pcr library
now end the pipeline give it a name
and run on cluster
in the output folder you will get two
important outputs
one is the pca plot in the pdf format
and second as a pca result table
in the pca table we can see pc1 pc2 and
pc3 that represents
the percentage variance of the data
you can also draw the scatter plots
based on these principal components
using excel
if you open another output you will find
the three pca plots that is pc1 versus
pc2 pc1 versus pc3 and pc2 versus pc3
two of which are shown here
from the pc plots based on the
mutability results we can clearly see
samples from 2009 and 2015 from clear
distant groups
further one of the samples from 2015
looks like an outlier this sample can be
removed from downstream analysis
this analysis indicates strains of p
falsely param that can be separated from
each other based on mutation frequency
information
thus it would be interesting to know
what are the important variants and
mutations in p falciparum between these
two ears
to learn more about the mutability
analysis and how do you interpret the
results
you can go to
the course number 10 on mutability
analysis and interpretation
under genomics section on omics logic
learn portal
for any questions you can reach out to
us directly at marketing at
omixlogic.com
and we'll be glad to assist you with
your questions